i want to start with uh the top five and
top sorry the top five in the bottom
five states for child support equity um
and there's some differences there you
know based on legislation versus what
what usually ends up happening did you
want me to put your
screen share up sure okay go ahead
so let me first say something about the
research that we have already published
on child support we've actually been
doing research on child support for
several years
we
have
we're sitting on a mountain of research
on child support
at one point we thought it would make
sense to do a report card on
state's child support guidelines the
same way we do on their custody laws
but we decided that
the the issue was too multifaceted there
were too many different disparate
factors that went into the child support
guidelines so but we didn't do that one
thing we did publish last year
was um this page on our website it's
under the uh work website and under
research and you you'll go to the child
support thing what we did was to uh take
a scenario a hypothetical scenario that
we constructed that takes a father who's
earning the median income in the u.s and
the mother who's earning the median
income for women in the u.s
and they had one child and then we
assumed that dad had the children 35 of
the time now at that point if
if both parents have at least 35 of the
time they both have the fixed costs of
you know housing and utilities and
things like that that are necessary to
have extra people living in the home so
we took out of the mix the housing costs
that the u.s department of agriculture
estimates child costs related
uh to
and said you know both parents have that
in their house so we take that out of
the mix and we calculated what the
usda
thought was the
cost of raising a child in each state
and so this interactive map will show
you for example and some people will be
interested in this contrast
in texas
under that scenario the
usda monthly cost of raising a child is
estimated to be 137 dollars a month
but the child support guidelines in
texas
uh and have the obligor paying 761
dollars a month
that's a pretty big discrepancy that's a
huge discrepancy and if you go across
the border just imagine two towns here a
couple miles apart one in texas and one
in new mexico
there the estimated child costs in new
mexico are 131 dollars
a month that's very close to what it was
in texas but the child sport guidelines
have a presumptive child support
obligation of 276.
so this map shows two different things
it shows the disparity between
the
uh actual child-related costs in the
states and what the presumptive child
support order is and then it shows the
the disparity really the the sort of um
inexplicable variation in uh child
support orders between say texas and uh
and new mexico so just to clarify don
like if
if the cost of raising a kid is 160 a
month in that state
and then the the difference goes up
let's say whatever it is 760 dollars
that's generally what the courts will
award
the other parent for child support
monthly if they're the primary caregiver
to the child exactly so
so it enriches the other parent
with significantly more than what's
required to raise that child yeah
absolutely part of the problem is that
um the the child support system in most
states is built on the presumption that
there is a sole custodian and a visitor
and so the idea is get as many of the
financial resources as possible in the
children's home
and that's what's best for children
and you know if the non-custodial parent
almost always the dad doesn't have as
much to live on well okay that's that's
too bad but you know we got to do what's
best for the children so it's not based
on what the child needs it's based on
what the court feels like they should
send over to the other parents house
that has the children for the most part
and a lot of it is explicitly lifestyle
continuity
ensuring that the lifestyle in the in
the custodial parents home doesn't go
down at all
so the problem of course is we know that
the research shows that it is best for
children to have two homes if the
parents are living apart and to be with
both parents roughly equal amount of
time
and the
child support guidelines really aren't
built on that model
let me just pause you for a second on um
tony if you can hear us uh there's a
request for you to drop the link for
whatever
don's got up on the screen so if you can
drop that link in the live chat then
that would help awesomely thanks
oh someone asked if this is behind a
paywall absolutely not no no i think he
was asking about the um cast itself but
but
all of these links that that dawn's
showing you right now um it's
sharedparenting.org and the link for
that is in the description below um i'm
hoping tony can hear me right now but um
don's colleague should be able to drop
the links in uh the live chat for you if
he can't then i'll just go oh there you
go right there
it should pop up in a second for you
guys go ahead don
so um
there is this disparity between the
states and there is this uh this gap
between what is an actual child expense
and what the presumptive transport uh
orders are you know we ask if this is
what the courts will typically order
under federal law the states have to
have a guideline child support
calculation and that guideline
child support calculation has to be
presumed to be the appropriate child
support order by the courts and so if
you're going to
challenge it you have to go to court and
get a court to say that there are
extenuating factors here that
allow the court to deviate
so um
on this interactive map which would be
the top five uh states or is that on a
different map that we're going to look
at
so
um
i think that
the map doesn't actually list the top
five states i'd have to look at the
underlying spreadsheet that we have here
and i don't have that offhand but texas
is a high state um california is fairly
high massachusetts is egregiously high
let's get massachusetts there what's the
difference it's very difficult to see on
my screen so um the the usda estimate of
the cost of raising the child would be
196 dollars a month and the uh child
support guidelines issue an order of 949
wow now
the problem that i see with that don and
i you know i wrote a book and i covered
in one of the chapters of my book why
smart men no longer marry
um
that that incentivizes the parent to
like one parent which is generally going
to be the mom
uh to
obtain custody of the children
because not only does it give her
unilateral you know for the most part
unilateral decision making on pretty
much everything where you live with
medical procedures religions all sorts
of stuff of course it's going to vary
from location location but it also moves
a significant part of the father's
resources to her and it's and it's
it's sad because they
they're generally not doing it because
they love the children more than anybody
else i mean
you know to argue that the mom loves the
children more than a father or the
children we do better under uh
the mother's care is
really an absurd statement but it's it's
really about money and control i mean
would you agree with that or is that
something that
you don't see eye to eye with me on don
um
so rich i don't talk about my divorce
very much um but but you're you're
encouraging me to to break that silence
and i will say this when
um i was the one who wanted the marriage
to end but i thought that we would go
through mediation and we would have a
dissolution and we would you know agree
to shared parenting and my ex was bound
and determined that if we were if the
marriage was going to end it was going
to be by her divorcing me so she went to
a lawyer another very aggressive lawyer
and i told my ex when
i served for the papers that i thought
we would mediate i thought we would have
shared parenting i was always a highly
involved father
and she said
i would never try to keep the kids away
from you the kids wouldn't stand for
that i know that but my lawyer says i
can't agree to shared parenting because
it might affect my child support
so
i know from personal experience that's
true i know from the experience of
working with so many divorced fathers
that that
that often is the sticking point in uh
getting shared parenting so i i do want
to talk about
some research that we are about to
publish that i think would be more
directly responsive to your
question about the best in worst states
uh
well we decided that it didn't make
sense to do a report card grading all
the states on their child support
guidelines overall because there are so
many different factors that go into it
how do we estimate child costs in the
first place what formula do they use to
to uh to apportion this between the two
parents most states use an income shares
model but texas for example we just
mentioned texas they use a percent of
obligor's income model very different
models and there are lots of things to
criticize about uh about the different
models that are used but what we decided
it did make sense to do a report card on
is the issue of the degree to which the
child's work guidelines of each state
either creates a barrier to share
parenting or facilitates shared
parenting
and the
results are very interesting
um all right so i think you said
something about the five four states i'm
sorry i can't give you the five first i
can give you the nine worst states all
right let's do the next th here are the
states alabama arkansas
oh although i think arkansas their law
is under uh revision now but alabama
arkansas connecticut georgia mississippi
new hampshire new york texas and
washington and why are these the nine
worst states because they don't have any
parenting time adjustment at all in
their child support guidelines and what
that means is
that
a father who has his children within 50
of the time
will presumptively pay exactly the same
amount in child support as a father who
never sees the children at all wow
and now that father who has kids 50 of
the time can get a deviation but the
father has to go to court he has to file
pleadings has to file evidence this
takes time
it's beyond the capability of most
parents to do on their own so it means
hiring a lawyer and courts are
reluctant to deviate from the child
support guidelines because some courts
believe that the federal government will
penalize the state if it deviates from
the guidelines too much that's false it
won't but
they think that
so
so we graded all of the um
states on really their parenting time
adjustment how do they divide
the
obligations of both
the mother and the father between the
two households
based on how much parenting time each of
the parents has and so there are those
nine states that have no parenting time
adjustment
a bunch of states let me get
the number here i think it's about 11 or
12 maybe 13 states um
do only slightly better they have a
parenting time adjustment but sometimes
the threshold for when the parenting
time adjustment kicks in is
extraordinarily high in fact in three
states it doesn't kick in until it's 50
50 parenting time
so a parent can have their children 49
of the time no parenting time adjustment
in those states
um
and in all of those cases the the
guidelines create a horrible cliff
effect and what that means is that it
makes a significant difference in child
support
depend on an insignificant difference in
parenting time
so
130 overnights
the child the non-residential parent
pays a whole lot more 131 overnights a
whole lot less well
if you want a recipe to make parents
fight
then build cliff effects into the child
support guidelines yeah
we see the same thing here don it's it's
a it's a line in the sand that starts at
40 percent so
if you
if you have your child 41 of the time or
more
then it's shared parenting there's no
there's no uh unilateral decision making
money doesn't really flow anywhere if
you if you generally have the same
income
but there's a big incentive to
to one parent to
to be the custodial caregiver to the
children
under the guise of the children need
their mother you know
and really i'm i'm
really sick of divorced professionals
complaining about parents fighting with
each other when in effect what the
divorce system does is to create a
system
where they will fight against one
another they throw them into a death
match against one another and say look
at these parents they're fighting
how how long has like i mean i would
argue that
this essentially rips apart the fabric
of society right because
you're like when it comes to marriage
generally speaking
men
you know it's high risk and it's slow
reward for men today and it's low risk
high reward for women
especially if the nod is untied because
pretty much all the laws are in their
favor um
it's it's a it's a very very difficult
scenario a lot of guys ask me this
question all the time like you know how
do i have kids rich you know like uh you
know is it safe to have kids and it's
like i just i just can't endorse it
today um now there's some strategies
that we're going to talk about here with
you right now don that are going to
cover some of the states that are
friendlier to father so i want to i want
to be able to give guys some of that
advice as well too
yeah
yeah will it uh marriage can be a
perilous thing and there are a lot no
one goes into it thinking the marriage
is going to break up now but we know
that a great many marriages do break up
and very often that breakup is
acrimonious
how long has it been that way by the way
so
one of the things that i find
fascinating is the history of custody um
and here it is in a quick thumbnail uh
for
many many years there was a presumption
that fathers got custody unless the
fathers were unfit
now that surprises everyone that was
true in the 1800s and earlier
and then the
tender years doctrine came into effect
the phrase tender years comes from a
court decision where a judge said you
cannot rip a baby from its mother's
breast during his tender years
and so there was a presumption that
mothers had custody and originally the
presumption was they would have custody
until the child was seven years old and
then the father would have cuss now talk
about something that's not particularly
father friendly you live with mom almost
exclusively for seven years and then at
seven you go to day out and live with
him almost exclusively when did that
change don
the the that
seven year sort of thing that was only
for a short period of time in the late
1800s and early 1900s and then
presumption of mother custody and in
many states it was a jury presumption it
was written into the law the statute
would say mother shall have custody
unless mother is unfit
and here's something that people need to
keep in mind when they think about
feminism it was the feminist law reform
in the 70s that went through and took
out the gendered language in custody
laws and so no state has a law that says
mother has custody unless mother is
unfit anymore so what did the states do
of course we know the difference between
de jury discrimination and de facto
discrimination the fact that it's not
written in the statutes anymore doesn't
mean that there's not discrimination in
the court behavior but what did the
states do when they couldn't have
gendered language in custody well they
put in the best interest of the child
standard
well the problem is there were not very
many custody battles
when
there was a presumptive father custody
of course there weren't that many
divorces then either but as a percentage
of the divorces there weren't very many
challenges to custody because moms knew
they wouldn't get custody unless they
could prove dad was unfit and when there
was a presumption of mother custody
there weren't very many challenges
because dads knew that they couldn't get
custody unless mom was unfit
so what happens when you put in the best
interest of the child standard well in
in all the years i've been dealing with
divorced couples i have never met a
parent who says
i know this isn't best for my child but
this is the custody arrangement i want
everyone thinks that the custody
arrangement they want is what's best for
their child now sometimes they're acting
in bad faith
they're vilifying the other parent in
their own mind but
no one believes that the custody
arrangements that they want is not in
the best interest of the child so when
they talk to their lawyer the lawyer
says oh the courts are going to do
what's in the best interest of the child
and they hear oh i'm going to win
yeah well that's what you think i mean
it's going to be something reasonable
like i see like i see my kids all the
time so that that's in the best interest
so that should continue but i've been a
highly involved father so et cetera yeah
you know then they slam into a brick
wall and then reality hits them
you